all right so this is a I guess kind of a
reread review no Avery review sorry of a
glitch is a glitch oh because people
just flip their on this one which
is usually like fine you know when they
do that while we serve like this I when
people are passionate about something is
like great be passionate about what you
love and talk about it but there is one
thing that we missed that we didn't
bring up and we didn't know going in uh
and that's a it was an April Fool's
episode um and the reason I wanted to do
in our video on this is because I Sur
wanted to start the dialogue does that
make a difference because that's the one
thing that everybody kept saying it's an
April Fool's joke it's an April Fool's
joke and you know like I say it like
this was sort of the thing that sort of
made it all okay um and a few other
issues would get to that too but you
know in terms of doesn't make a
difference I would argue I think it does
a little bit but I don't think it saves
everything I don't think it like
clarifies everything because when you
say something is there's no
quote/unquote right or wrong way to do
an April Fool's joke it's not like you
know there's a book written here's how
to do it um but at the same time I've
seen them done well and I've seen them
done badly and for me it's like okay
it's something different and even if
it's not Canon or relate to the rest of
the episode and it's sort of there to
kind of annoy you whatever that's fine
uh for me my big issue is that if it's
gonna be an April Fool's joke you either
have to put a lot of effort into it or
just no effort at all and the funny
thing about it is that even though like
I wasn't a fan of the style of the art
style um you could still tell there's
effort going into it but not enough to
be like wow isn't that something isn't
this really amazing um I actually would
have to disagree with that and on which
one uh and know my opinion on this
episode has not changed at all but no I
think a lot of effort actually went into
it I mean I'm not a fan of his style for
an adventure time episode
I mean his style is neat it's different
it's something strange and
all that stuff he wants to do that but
for adventure time I didn't like it
but yeah a lot of effort I think
actually went into this episode you
think so I mean your custom oh okay I
like with unlaid put this way the you
know when the glitch starts you know in
the beginning it's like oh that's kind
of cool like they're really messing with
it you know make it kind of you know
glitchy and annoying and stuff but then
you find out this is gonna be throughout
the whole episode and it's you know just
grating on your eyes and stuff like that
I thank myself a free lifer was going
into this it they would make it where
was more pleasing to look at and most of
the time it's like it's not bad CG I
mean I've seen much worse I'm sure you
have too you know like with food fight
and stuff like that but even then it's
sort of like this weird mix of it's not
that there's no effort put in but it's
not like wow wasn't that animation
incredible what's the detail and
everything is that you know it's if
there was like a lot of effort like you
know looking at the Candy Kingdom it was
something like I want say Pixar but you
know it's like CG has come a long way
you know especially with landscapes and
it just looked like they served took the
very simple drawings that just made them
circular you know gave them shadows well
you know good shadows you know but still
you know it not much detail to it Walter
Chetan with some of the people in the
comment section I found out that's his
style yeah yeah and I know it's very
minimalistic in that sense and whatnot
I'm not fond of it overall but I
understand why he did it her and that's
so I mean I can't it is kind of like
comparing apples and oranges
you know comparing Pixar to this it's
like comparing Pixar to CG done back in
the 90s mmm it's it's not gonna flow
very well by comparison you know you
know you have a low-budget show
Adventure Time alright I shouldn't say
venture time you have a low-budget movie
compared to Pixar which is a high-budget
movie you know you're gonna have
professionals working on it with Pixar
and you're gonna have probably not so
professionals working on it in this one
and there's gonna be a difference in
quality and I think this guy's just like
yeah this is the way I like doing it
suck it and you know what honestly more
power to the guy oh and again I'm not
gonna like it
he chose that I don't like it well I
guess I mean like if you and we says
before at the end of review to eat
because this guy does apparently have a
phyla wings no way if you like this
guy's style and you like the episode
more power to ya I mean there's nothing
like no you are wrong this can do you
know what we're talking about just what
we enjoyed here um and and whether or
not it being an April Fool's episode
does change anything um like I said I
give it a bit more leeway you know
because of it but I still I'm still not
a fan because for I don't furred okay
the episode we just watched here another
five short graybles by not giving us the
answer I think of what that better April
Fool's joke yeah that's my guy I think
that seemed to fit and that's or if
you're gonna do something different do
something totally different do like when
Adult Swim showed the room you know
clearly require no effort they just need
to pay for the rights to show it it's
not even a cartoon has nothing to do
with anything and you know go from there
uh and I don't know the fact that this
seemed to it's still our characters it's
still an adventure it doesn't connect to
you know it's technically not canon but
even though they're not like you said
you know there's there's a part where
like Jake loves II like his elbow was
flirting with Bubblegum's hand yeah the
whole time bubblegum is making out with
her own hand and yeah which like I said
if if the whole episode nobody is doing
what they traditionally do like that's
that's fine it's like go all the way
with it you know if you're gonna do an
April Fool's joke you know don't don't
kind of half-ass it you know really make
it where it's like this makes no sense
whatsoever and it's a waste of time or
make it where it's like it's a normal
episode but like one thing is off you
know like the another five short
graybles well it's like The Drew Carey
episodes where you watch the episodes
and throughout the whole thing there are
a bunch of things wrong with it
mmm everyone swelled let's say someone's
name wrong and add something wrong in
the background they'll have the wrong
sound effect and at the end that's kind
of like a contest thing yeah you know
riding with era all the mistakes that
would have been kind of neat a nice
little April Fool's thing where instead
of you know is the whole episode Finn's
call
you know everyone Gunter yeah you're
different
this is actually finest April Fool's
episode for me hmm it's fine I guess I
just I think you can do an April Fool's
episode it can be canon and you can
still get away with being bizarre and
silly well you were bringing on via the
South Park when they were gonna reveal
Cartman's father and instead they did
the Terrance and Phillip episode which
people hated when it came out and I I'm
sorry half and half cuz I really hated
it too because I want to see the episode
but at the same time when it just says
April Fool's and then you play this
obnoxious episode it's like okay I'll
give you balls you went all the way with
this stupid thing you know that you
actually just shown a Terrance and
Phillip episode you acknowledge it's
April Fool's um so I don't know why I
give it a touch more leeway but it still
I it's like it's adventure time and
these people are so good at coming up
with different ways of doing things that
for this to sort of be like a CG episode
about a glitch and you know not too much
else uh uh it didn't do it for me you
know but I thought that was fair to
address and yet the other thing too is
that a lot of people were saying you
know your TV's too bright it actually
looks great it looks unbelievable so
I've looked up about three or four other
versions of this it was it wasn't the TV
guy you know I'm sure it's his style
don't get me wrong and it's like fair
enough if you like it fine but it's like
Finn's hat was still blending into his
skin I mean it's like you could barely
tell the color different everything was
overexposed it's it's his style that's
fine I just don't care for it how about
we make them a deal quote-unquote okay
when it gets released on DVD we will
watch the DVD version or it's not a
torrent it's nothing online the DVD is
made for TV so therefore we can kind of
rewatch it make a little comment later
on saying we finally watched the
official version okay I mean if they do
that if they've released on DVD I know
they're very strange about which ones no
no like they just released season three
okay so they are going by okay yeah they
released packs everyone's - no earned
packs like single discs with like a
bunch of episodes from all over the
place
but as far as they know they have not
released officially a glitches glitch
okay so I mean we'll check it out again
you know we'll get back I'm saying all
the pictures all the other videos all
that I mean like I've gone to a couple
different sources
no yeah on why it's not like I just
watch this other video I looked right
there - it's like no I looked at a
couple different Clips different
pictures and it's it all kinda looks
like the one that I I saw so like I said
it's it's not my thing you know and he's
got a fanbase it's not like no he
destroyed adventure time or he's
anything bad it's just we didn't care
for it and I think the fact that it is
an April Fool's joke
it does help but I don't think it saves
it from me it's still it it didn't do it
for me but if it did for you great like
I said the end of the episode we said we
could totally see how someone would like
this episode like it's not with you know
beyond the realms of reason you know
it's just not something that we could
grasp on to as yeah you know as a
venture time fans so and by the way I
did learn again from the people in the
comment section that the hair video was
actually released like a few days
beforehand as a promo like a hidden
promo if you will for the episode so was
it I thought it was like his original
video that he was kind of just like
inserting it where did they play I was
like oh I something I think so I think
it was online and it was also kind of
like shorts in between episodes it was
kind of like a weird thing I could be
wrong with that too but uh no I was
wrong and I will fully admit that I was
wrong with that but but and I forgot to
mention the first time we the snake
spider yeah was actually awesome I did
love that design very much so and it
kept I keep forgetting to bring it up
because we talked about other things and
get out but yeah I really did like the
snake spider thing that was fun yeah and
there's definitely more to things I
thought were kind of creative economy
you know but yeah like I say for an
April Fool's joke it's like if you're
gonna do it man just like hit us in the
gut with something either just throw
make like the most incredible CG
creative world ever and it's only a
couple seconds long and they the rest
looks like crap you know there is
something or like just throw something
at us that
makes no sense everything's outfits it
everything's insane or it has nothing to
do with adventure time II for me it's
like just go balls out don't do this
kind of you know half and half and for
me like I said I know a lot of people
like it it's just I I didn't
particularly care for it actually I'd be
kind of Awesome now that I'm thinking
about it so the episode starts with the
theme where it's like top of the line
like Pixar DreamWorks and all that yeah
like this incredible backdrop but as
it's the episode slowly goes along it
degrades and degrades and degrades like
their budget is slowly disappearing
orally and it's just stick figure or
maybe you could have like this
incredible backdrop but the main
characters look like crap you know like
they're just horribly CJD I mean like I
said something out foodfight you know
they move like puppets or some Abby just
really really bad really don't like food
fight it's the worst anime film ever
seen Wow never saw it so good man I
don't change my opinion though I feel
this was completely pointless yeah yeah
I guess hella you think she's always
like if you want so like I I fellas
worth talking about the April Fool's
element whether or not that like excuses
everything cuz like I think it's
important to acknowledge you know like
when something was an April Fool's joke
it does that does that clear out
everything is so let's say you go to a
theater to see a movie and you know you
go in there and let's say your ticket
was even free and you go in and you sit
down you're gonna watch you know Star
Wars being re-released original versions
not the you know special SuperDuper
editions you sit done and then they
start playing food fight play food fight
for the entire time does that excuse or
make it okay because it's April Fool's I
mean for me it's like no that's just
kind of like being a jacket you know and
I again I like the episode if you want
to I'm all fine with that because
there's stuff I like that people hate
but I mean I don't want to sit there and
say oh yeah you can do whatever you
wanted April Fool's Day because lo it's
April Fool
you know what it is I I think there is
at a United the same idea we have such a
respect for April Fool's
and there is a right way to do it and
people think oh we can do whatever you
want no there's a very funny clever way
of doing April Fool's yeah you know and
I think when when it's not quite met or
whatever or you know you don't care for
it's kind of like well what could they
have done oh what's a better way to do
this uh because there's this idea of
just yeah well anyone could do April
Fool's on anything goes cuz it's April
Fool's then it's like sure like I said
there's no right or wrong way but
there's if you want to be funny and you
want to be enjoyable and clever and
smart and show hey I understand this
holiday if you will um you know I I
think you got to go all out of it you
just gotta put the effort into it he got
to be really smart and really clever
it's the opposite end maybe that
opposite end also though in the comments
so I want to bring up our April Fool's
and they said God yours was just stupid
and retarded and all that's okay that's
fine I accept that but we also came up
with that in a matter of like five
minutes and on top of that it's full of
so many of you okay
there were so you have no idea how many
people were like where is this episode
this episode that almost got that was
almost an April Fool's on that's cuz we
didn't think anybody would fall yeah
that's kind of more what it was is that
we were like this is gonna be done but
whatever but no that's my thing is that
we had like but because initially he
wanted us to switch people I and I
thought that was kind of lame and I came
up and I said I'm a terrible actor I
wouldn't be able to pull off Doug in any
way shape or form so we just kind of
talked about it for like five minutes
and we came up with this BS idea so if
we're not like a show where we have
months of advance work or any of that
stuff or time to plot this out it was
literally let's just try this but but
even then it's like okay you could have
gone along with the us getting a
different clothes but you're like I just
don't think they'll wear like there's
something better you know like there is
something better that can be that and I
wasn't against I'm like all right let's
have ideas yeah it's that Cersei
mentality where it's like you know but
week I've done it just at April Fool's
whatever but it's like no we wanted
something a little funny around a little
better and I
like an episode a lot of people like
that episode you know and yeah I think I
think it's their first time at Ewing now
it gets an April Fool's episode actually
yeah well well this dialogue is not
canon again I miss I'm still playing me
okay fair enough
I like playing with myself we'll stop
there
can i play with you please